[Applause]
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode the
kos
and today i bring you a statue that won
the poll my free statue poll i had uh
three statues to choose from
it was uh ultimate captain america it
was uh peter parker spider-man
and it was miles morales spider-man and
i'm pretty sure
you know who won today i bring you
premium format
miles morales spider-man
now a lot of you guys are familiar with
miles morales spider-man from
enter the spidey verse or the
spider-man game from uh sony playstation
where miles morales was introduced into
those worlds
well i'm familiar with miles morales
from marvel comics
and how miles morales came to be
uh he witnessed peter parker
die uh the green goblin from the
ultimate universe uh was on a quest
to replicate the spider-man
uh serum to make spider-man again
that spider got out because miles
morales
uncle is the prowler and it went home
with him in the bag
and it bit miles morales and he was
dealing with his powers or learning his
powers
uh in the shadows while spider-man was
you know in the city and fighting well
he got a chance to witness spider-man
actually die in that universe and i know
that would be a terrible take
uh for the young children to watch
you know an mcu um spider-man or
a sony spider-man movie so they went in
a different direction
and i understand it i totally get it you
know this spider-man is a spider-man
that
my son is growing up with he identifies
with
he knows of peter parker spider-man you
know
um we dress up every halloween
in our costumes so he's very fond of him
but uh miles morales spider-man is the
spider-man that
he identifies with now and it's uh
a beautiful thing because like my son
miles morales is uh black and latino
and that goes a long way
with identifying with the the youth of
today
you know um or pardon me it is
hot trust me when i'm telling you
this new york city heat is off the chain
this summer um
over 100 degrees and i got central ac
down here
it's crazy um
but again you know spider-man
has made a big impact
impact especially into the spidey verse
right
so let's give you a couple of
differences between uh peter parker
spider-man
and miles morales spider-man uh peter
parker spider-man
is pretty straight up uh speed agility
power and he has spidey sense
he can stick to walls miles morales
uh has all those but
also at the same time miles morales
has camouflage his
speed is a little bit faster uh
and i believe that has to do with the
age because uh
he got his spidey
powers at a younger age than uh peter
parker spider-man
uh peter parker got his stuff uh
later on in high school
and uh miles morales got it a little bit
earlier on
so also he has this like this knockout
power
right and he has a camouflage
uh like i was talking about where he can
go completely
invisible not to be seen
and then you know like come behind the
character
knock him out and or or you know use his
knockout power so they gave him a little
bit extra
and he's a little bit you know
more than the average spiderman you know
in my opinion i love the suit now i know
you guys look at the into the spidey
verse suit
where he's wearing jordans and he has
the hoodie on
and all that stuff i love this
suit this suit is
in its simplicity is very
intricate this suit this suit
brings back the feeling of when you were
supposed to get the
first uh black and white spider-man suit
this was a rendition
of a black and red suit and i believe
they used this uh to conceive miles
morales suit
which is very nice well
let's get into the statue right so now
this statue it
flows like mal's morales it has a
fluidity about it
that is astonishing when you start to
look at the pieces
like the venom base is a liquid
base and it flows upward
into miles morales as miles morales
is going down into the venom statue
and the venom statue mouth is open the
tongue
is weaving out as his ten trails is
trying to wrap around spite of miles
morales smite
spiderman and he's like
using him as a stepping stone to get
past
now i was pretty concerned in the
beginning with the
hand but it was a reinforced hand
miles morales himself isn't as heavy
as the base which is venom um
also i i didn't like one thing of it
right the statue
the off hand that's sticking out
that hand it just slides in it does it's
not magnetized
right but i i would have thought that
they would magnetize it but it's not so
that's a little bit of a concern for me
over a period of time
but other than that the paint
applications is perfect
the reds is like a metallic plasticky
finish
which looks fantastic to me uh the black
is a matte black
so the reds actually stand out and pop
the white of the eyes
actually popped also one thing i didn't
like
was the teeth the teeth on the venom
statue
right there on the on them on the mouth
morale section
of the venom they're very sharp they
they
actually will cut you but they look like
gums it looks like a a plant right
you know you know like those those the
venus fly traps it looks like that
but i would have liked for them to make
the teeth
actually white actually look like
something that can actually damage you
because right there it doesn't look as
lethal
as you may think but the clear coat
resin
the gums the whale looks
uh wet it looks moist
pause and the the
the the way venom actually looks
is insane i can't lie
i thought this statue was pretty basic
until i got a chance to get up close to
it and see it for what it is
the dynamic pose of miles morales and
this is the
i think his hallmark speed agility
agility and the fact that
miles is in a position
of dominating without dominating
the statue itself it's
fantastic it's utterly spider-man
and it's a marvel to look at well
this is the part in the video what i'm
going to ask you to like follow and
subscribe
and also hit that join button hit that
join button
you know where that joint button is the
join button is right there at the bottom
hit the join button so you can see a lot
of the videos that we have in the
background when you join the realm
oh if you want to see that tattoo video
that i got of the iop logo
it's there so hit that join button and
you get a chance to see the kid
go through all the pain that was kind of
crazy thank you will me hood
anyway you can see me sundays at 1 pm
at iron lords podcast where we talk
video games we talk uh
a lot of the stuff that goes on
sometimes combat talk because we have
combat talk with the king and we can see
exactly where the industry is going to
go
forward when we're talking about
playstation 5 and xbox series x
this week is a huge week for xbox so
i hope you guys tune in also watch laura
cognito
and with the last word with ivantis
i'm telling you that is the best destiny
podcast
that is on the web and if you guys have
not seen it please tune into it and
definitely check it out
well stick around watch the video and
you can see this
statue in all his glory without this guy
talking
until next week when i give you
somebody that can literally wipe out the
universe
with a snap of his finger
stay collecting
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
people
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
everybody
okay
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
thank you
everybody
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
thank you
thank you
everybody
[Music]
i rule
[Music]
you